hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John so I got a call from Andrew Gordon
saying hey dude do you remember a couple
years ago when you saw that trailer when
they were gonna reimagine the obi-wan
vs. Darth Vader fight from episode 4
yeah hello they've just released it then
I went through some comments I'm like oh
there's a lot of people requests
we just gotta hop right into this guy's
it's blowing up in views right now this
is from the channel F exit in post fix
it in post I remember that I saw the
trailer a few times there we go class
fight scene even
[Music]
Wow this seems like it was a [ __ ] to
put together yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
great
[Music]
nice he has courage good gets himself
killed
[Music]
[Music]
ouch Oh headbutt with the helmet yeah
horse put Wow
he's soul
[Music]
just leave this party protect you who
your friend is she seems okay if we
could get to it just hope the own tank
at the track of me Mike I know I like
the new choice of music
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
looked very difficult to put so yeah I
get why it took so long yeah that was
well worth the wait oh yeah I mean most
of that time went to resurrecting Sir
Alec Guinness so that he could appear
yeah it was really easy my only like
slight nitpick is sometimes the
superimposed face of alligators looked a
little funky other than that it was
great I'm waiting forever to watch Darth
Vader fight like that oh yeah yeah that
was one of my things with a new hope was
this fight was something that could have
always been improved upon you know is
the first Star Wars movie it already had
so much difficulty just assembling that
movie together
do you imagine if this was the original
fight on this game have had people
already lost their [ __ ] over stuff we're
doing a lot are you way more if that was
the original fight back then oh yeah one
fight scenes especially for like sci-fi
movies would be in a different place
than they are now I would imagine yeah
we had this kind of camera work and yeah
this kind of choreography going into it
I love the sensibility they brought into
the camera work because it does kind of
make an interesting juxtaposition
between the old shots and the new shots
you know because it is very sleek in the
way that they've chosen to capture a lot
of these things and I thought it was
really smart of the editing choice to
make it blend in with the actual scene
yeah that was taking place cutting back
and forth between Han Solo Luke Leia all
them Chewbacca
cutting back and forth between teeth oh
yes absolutely well that's right and
just happened like a few days ago didn't
it yeah rest in peace transition it back
into this going back into though the
sequences to make it feel like a
complete scene and how it could have
worked within the movie itself because
if it was just showing the fight I
wonder how it would work between cutting
back and forth but you know and like I'm
now I'm half tempted to be like man
maybe they should just read it keep the
movie the way it is just insert this in
there just to see how it all work
yeah terms of emotional weight in
context do you think like maybe that'll
be the thing that fans actually do get
on board with this like don't go back
and CGI the creatures and stuff just go
back and make some of the fights a
little more yeah cuz I was a you know as
tight as time has gone on that fight has
not aged well the original one and even
some of the lightsaber effect I believe
it is obi-wan
Obi's lightsaber which looks a little
often visuals to improve upon it here I
thought the choreography was great I
loved it whenever Darth Vader he got
brutal like when he would just use one
hand or like use his face or headbutt
him at one point that was so cool man or
even just those moments where they've
got the sabers like locked together and
they're like pushing on the other and
just you can feel the intensity yeah I
love the emotional weight of it and even
including some of the the dialogue in
terms of echoing flashback audio of the
prequels I thought was really smartly
chosen he had one big takeaway that
we're all gonna have with this is
bringing this version of Darth Vader to
life he the closest thing we got and I
think in the live-action ones and full
Darth Vader costume was was rogue one
that hallway fight which was very
short-lived but the other thing too is
you get some badass obi-wan Kenobi
moments here yeah it's cool the CD is
much older here so there were a couple
moments like when he got his back thrown
against the wall room like it does
really showcase the skill set that
obi-wan Kenobi has and how powerful
obi-wan is and it drives home that line
to when he's like if you strike me down
now I'm gonna come back even more
powerful than you can imagine like yeah
intensity of the fight increased I feel
like it gives it a little extra oomph to
that wine you know seriously guys
congratulations if if you're watching if
you happen to be watching it here for
the first time - OH - they go to their
channel watch the original video give it
a like subscribe to these guys right
away because this is just incredible
seriously congratulations again guys
this is like the best thing about this
but also the under par with the one'd to
check the lightsaber forces it next to
obi-wan Kenobi's head it's like yeah
then they pick you side of me is like
what she just ordered his head but the
other side is that was really cool yeah
you know for these things I I feel less
of a need to nitpick oh yeah they're
enjoying it yeah you know alright well
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation subscribe to fix it in post yeah
that's what you should most importantly
do click the notification bell for our
channel if you liked this video give it
a like we'll catch you guys soon